hey guys it's Justine and I'm here with
the row no okay have you seen it's okay
it's a little bit outdated at this point
but the face app the filter when
everybody's making themselves look old
oh my gosh I saw that but I never did it
well there's all this crazy stuff and
people like they're stealing your image
your dad of whatever anyway I mean if
you're using the Internet your data is
being stolen did you steal my dad let me
down and you tell me that you just you
just stole my dad okay you come on my
dog so I'm stealing your data you can
see my data you can have what we're
gonna do today we're gonna use it
because you're really downloaded I'm
going to face half our dogs and do like
the aid shelters yeah I've been putting
bangs on Maddie and everyone thinks that
they're real so I'm gonna take a few
pictures they sit you are sitting okay
good boy okay look here hey look at the
cam look here blueberry muffin sometimes
it's poo berry muffin okay everyone look
here hey could you right here right here
that's my girl okay I got it here you go
we didn't even plan this we were just
showed up and tied up yeah we did not
get in row surprise me with something
she cloned our dogs if you guys see the
video a little leave those encryption
and annotation it's Auto jamming you
have to go see it I did this months ago
I didn't tell Justine and I honestly
forgot about it and then it showed up in
the mail and I was like oh so go check
it out I'm not gonna say anymore it's
incredible it's gonna be great basically
what my entire phone looks like I know I
mean now my doesn't do okay now I don't
know if this gonna work I know it works
for Maddie he's thinking what are you
doing I mean there may not I don't think
there may be a pee-pee spot there Oh poo
bury all right no Maddie is really
getting in there oh I'm not spawn I mean
he is yeah this is great it's so great
because obviously when you do this with
people you can change your ears oh my
gosh she doesn't work so well so let's
see what Maddie looks like with makeup
oh thanks and me oh this is Maddie
whoa looking like hot girl summer old so
that's evening look for hostesses when
he goes out at night this looks like the
Joker put smiles on people so you can
make them smile you have that friend who
likes didn't smile where do you see the
no no I don't even ears I know who are
left there's so white I mean they're
like whiter than his hair but can you
even oh my gosh that's a lot of teeth oh
my gosh I have this wasn't so hard
sometimes to get dogs to wear sunglasses
yes or smile with human teeth I mean
that's all you're like no like I'm 80
but I have a little filler like baby I'm
gonna have to try it on myself and see
so this is what he look like before okay
there's before I mean I think it's just
really don't wrinkle him up a little bit
he looks a little dryer Okies turn I
hope it does I really think it might be
because Maddie's hair looks like he's a
woman he has a womanly woman with them
like a nice long haircut oh my gosh I
have a wig I'm gonna go get it go got a
wig if it means hair to think it's a
human I got a wig well I guess while
she's doing that I'm gonna face out
myself as grandmother I just seen it's
my future okay your Halloween and this
is what it looks like as just the old
filter you can also do the young filter
which doesn't like do that much you look
the same
oh there right okay that like that like
puffs your eyes out all weird okay you
look like a different person
that's not a suit it's like your face
got bigger it is really fascinating oh
my gosh that actually did a really good
job oh my gosh can you meet me at ladies
yeah you
I once had to cut bangs on myself
because I work a blood vessel in my eye
and then I hide it it's so fun ah so you
can see like what you don't like as like
really dark hair or like what about
unnatural hair colors just like natural
hair class okay no no I already look
absurd they don't ever do this
whoa hello saathi what kind of beard
would you rock if you were dude if
wouldn't it be really looters um would
you do a goatee get a little chin beard
would you do a full beard
I feel okay I think maybe I'm kind of
into the little hipster a good I like
that it's much too ashy and beer it's
nice the style at the bottom okay I love
you very much I'm sorry about my vision
we don't even need the app and we've got
real life this is your disguise okay
your purse wait oh gosh yes yes just
leave missus of making it they they're
nice here it is the photo that we have
taken is it the ears please work please
work please work she's a person no do I
think that it's I'm not sure I don't
understand so this works for some dogs
but yeah all dog we're gonna pick up any
of their faces from you let's see what I
see a lady's face so weird I can't
believe it without Maddie has bangs not
telling us something like he's like a
little human he maybe are you like
people don't mind movie where there's a
person inside you the Pokemon movie I
didn't see it
detective peek now is room for you get
hold of em oh I thought about my Google
Play Oh
if you ever want to watch it we could
have a movie night but there's more
surprises than that are you doing I
you want to tell us right now sorry for
the watch oh no no my god oh my god oh
my god it's me oh my gosh can we make me
an old lady okay okay okay got some
terrible zombies on your phone now you
have the worst selfies on there oh but
we are going to enhance them yes we can
make you smile oh you didn't know that
look at that weird what is that face I
don't know but hold on looks like when
you don't know your cameras oh my god
saved us I'm saving it cuz I'm making
this your phone like when you call
please do oh my god like a small smile
okay
wait oh my gosh oh that's big I mean
that's my whole face is like this is my
favorite though whoa upset oh my gosh
it's so great upset it's just like that
right amount of pout you know our foods
not being delivered or something like
yeah so let's do the young to filter why
have my eyebrows get bigger this just
looks like what I don't know like you
just decide just like just look like
like they're brightening my face I'm a
moment it all a huge you are let's do
the cool old different thing maybe it's
just like what's the makeup on you maybe
a little splash of Napa oh I love this
so much I love all the wrinkles and all
the lines I think that's really good but
she's really pink in the face and I just
don't go outside as much as people think
I want a face tattoo okay oh yeah that's
really
what about the stars mighty like Harry
Potter
oh my god send me the one with a
lightning bolt I wonder that Harry
Potter so bad does this do you can oh
that did a really good job what that was
really cool actually look I'm Harry
Potter in the city you are Harry Potter
on the beach you want to go to Venice
yes
you only need Hogwarts castle they don't
even have it well I don't look for a
castle Justine do they have anything
that looks like a castle is Larry behind
you
nightfall creepy for us that's it I mean
I mean the creepy forest sets by
Hogwarts castle you guys know what I'm
talking about
that's it that was the face app I am so
glad you got to experience this because
it's so silly thank you so much for
being in my video this is great you guys
have to go see the video we did in her
channel it's amazing yeah again cloning
there's cloning involved I surprised
Justine I I told her about this like
months ago and I was like so I did
something and months later it happened
we'll go check it out for legal
description annotations go subscribe to
Rose channel if you're not already and
of course I have a huge playlist of all
of our videos oh yeah so if you really
you know have nothing to do for the next
three days feel free to watch all of
those oh wow yeah they're good we'll see
you guys later bye
[Music]